[موسيقى]
بدات يسيره عند شرحها لنا على الخرائط
جوله حصريه يرافق فيها قوات حرس الحدود
العراقيه لرصد الاوضاع الامنيه المتوتره
على الحدود مع ايران وتركيا
لكنهم ابلغون ان المهمه على الارض ستكون
اصعب بكثير لم يمضي وقت طويل حتى تبين ذلك
ثلوج وتضاريس وعره ابطات حركهنا ثم
اوقفتها قبل ان نكمل سيرنا عناصر الحرس
يقولون ان هذا اقل ما يواجهونه لتنفيذ خطه
مراقبه الحدود التي وضعتها بغداد شهر
اكتوبر الماضي
[موسيقى]
هنا العراق وهذه ايران وصلنا الى اخر نقطه
حدوديه بين البلدين جبل كودو هذا الجبل
الذي كان مهما في القتال بين الجانبين
اثناء الحرب بين البلدين ثم بعد الحرب بقي
حقل الغامن وضع امي استغلته جماعه مسلحه
للتسلل والتمركز والانتشار لكن هذا الوضع
انتهى منذ سته اشهر فقط حينما وصلت قوات
الحدود لاول مره منذ
1991 الى هذا الجبل اسعى العراق لتثبيت
سياده على ارضه ولسد ذرائع جارته افتتحجج
طهران بعمليه التسلل وبانتشار جماعات
معارضه للنظام الايراني لتشن ضربات على
مواقع داخل العراق
بعد وصولنا هنا بعد سته اشهر حتى الان لم
يحصل اي حاله تسلل او تهريب في هذه
المنطقه لاننا الان نحن على خط الصفر بين
الحدود العراقيه الايرانيه وهذه كما ترون
نقطه ايرانيه مقابل مخافر الحدوديه
العراقيه يهدف العراق الى نشر قواتها على
كل الحدود مع ايران حتى في المساحات التي
كانت خاليه لعقوده بس عن يقول انه يحتاج
لتحقيقه الى طائره مسيره تراقب الحركه في
المنطقه كما يحتاج لعدد اكبر من عناصر قوه
الحدود ولتزويدهم باسلحه المتطوره
[موسيقى]
من الحدود العراقيه الايرانيه الى حدود
العراق وتركيا وصلنا نرافق قوات حرس
الحدود العراقيه في هذه الرحله الخاصه لنا
لنواكب تنفيذ المرحله الاولى من خطه نشر
القوات العراقيه مرحله مخصصه للمثلث
الحدودي العراقي التركي الايرانيه
على حدود تركيا رزمه عنوانها واحد حزب
العمال كردستاني الذي ينتشر منذ عقود في
مواقع مختلفه في العراق منها اقليم
كردستان كانت اكو تواجد لمسلحي حزب العمال
الكردستاني في بعض مناطقنا ولكن بعد تقدم
قوات الحدود العراقيه وفي معاونه لهذه
المناطق لم يبقى اي مسلح
في هذه المناطق وتم بناء قلاع
لقواتنا الحرس الحدود القوات البيشمرقه
موجودنا وموجوده خلفنا هي تدعم قوات حرس
حدود في هذه المنطقه اكو برنامج الحكومه
المركزيه والحكومه اقليم كردستان
نتوزع على الشريط الحدودي على خط الصفر
نفتح مخافر وتواجد بها القوات الحدود لكن
القرار العراقي بالانتشار لا يكفي فهناك
تفاهمات سياسيه لابد من التوصل اليها بين
بغداد وانقره تحديات امنيه بشان قبول حزب
العمال الكردستاني بالواقع الجديد الصعاب
قوه البيشمر في اقليم كردستان
لموقعها الثاني على الحدود
ساره بن عيشوبه العربيه كردستان العراق